today we have a fantastic opportunity to
learn from dr. journey listen who's
going to tell us about genetic
anthropology's anybody ever heard
genetic anthropology before you have
okay the rest of us are in for a treat
because we're going to learn about how
we can see human history in spit all
right so help me welcome to dr. listen
to the point hi thanks for having me
today i want to thank science saturdays
and dr. Ramirez for inviting me to come
talk today so I'm going to talk today
about some of my research as a genetic
anthropologist or anthropological
geneticist whichever is easiest for you
to say it doesn't matter so anthropology
is as a science it's actually a social
science and it's the study of the
origins and behavior of humans as a
species and in universities in the
United States anthropology is divided up
into four subfields so what people
commonly think of when they think of
anthropology is probably cultural
anthropology so cultural anthropologists
would study a particular group of people
a particular population they might study
their marriage practices their birth
practices linguistic anthropologists
study languages the the differences and
similarities between different languages
archaeologists our anthropologists who
use artifacts to study the origins of
human so anything that that a human
population might have left behind
whether it's a garbage pile or the
foundation of a home or fragments of
pottery and biological anthropologists
or physical anthropologists which is
what I am use biological data to study
the the origins and behavior of humans
so
anthropologists overall are interested
in looking at the differences between
human populations that you see today and
trying to figure out how they got that
way so sort of looking at at human
variation whether its behavior or
language or or physical differences
between human populations and then
trying to figure out what happened in
the past to make to make that variation
to make us look the way we are today the
main to make us behave the way we are
today so there are different kinds of
different kinds of data that physical
anthropologists can collect to try to
understand human history and and how we
got to be the way we are today these are
pictures of some people who were my
professors when I was in graduate school
at NYU and and they each collect
different kinds of data as physical
anthropologists so at the top you can
see somebody these are people who are
working at a site in Tanzania where they
are collecting fossils and they're
looking at they're collecting data from
fossils to learn about what human
ancestors might have looked like in the
past this is somebody who's an expert on
teeth human teeth but also the shapes of
of teeth of human ancestors and human
relatives like other monkeys and apes
this is somebody who studies baboon
behavior specifically their mating
behavior and and mating between
different species of baboons this is
somebody who's studying the behavior of
other kinds of monkeys in South America
you could see he's almost up to his neck
in water and he's he's um he's looking
up into the trees because he's watching
the behavior of the monkeys and this is
this was my advisor this is a in a
genetics lab at NYU and so this is
somebody who uses genetic data to study
both human populations but also
populations of human relatives so other
other monkey's and end Apes and this is
somebody who is a she's digging at a
site for four bones for the remains of
humans and she studies the the shapes of
the bones from different populations so
that she can compare them to each other
so so physical anthropologists want to
look typically look at a variation that
you find in in modern human populations
and then try to use that information to
piece together the past like like a
puzzle so you can use genetic
information to do this which is what I
do and this map of the world sort of
shows some of the timings of some of the
ancient human migrations so based on
both evidence from fossils and from
genetics we've kind of been able to
piece together the history of ancient
human migrations and so what the the
numbers on this map indicate or the
timings of some of the the large
movements of humans around the globe so
we know that humans as a species
originated in Africa maybe close to
200,000 years ago and at around a
hundred thousand years they some human
populations left Africa they might not
have gotten that far but by 40,000 years
ago there were human populations in
Europe and Central Asia and Australia
and then more recently somewhere between
50,000 and 35,000 years ago when there
was more land exposed here because sea
levels would have been lower at that at
that time if there were there was more
water locked up in glaciers humans could
have walked across a land bridge here
into the Americas and this map is is
kind of simplistic you know humans are
constantly migrating and they don't you
know move in just in one direction like
these simple arrows would indicate their
you know moving back and forth and but
if you put all of the arrows that that
would really reflect all human
migrations you would be able to see the
map anymore so so this is just a
simplistic map showing some ancient
human migrations that we've been able to
to figure out using both fossil evidence
and genetic evidence so genetic evidence
comes from a molecule called DNA
deoxyribonucleic acid and some people
may have already learned some about
something about it in school and you may
hear about it in the news or on the
Discovery Channel or things like that so
I'm just going to do a really quick
review of what DNA is so it's it's a
molecule that has two strands that are
sort of wound together into this helix
and in the middle you can see what looks
like the rungs of a ladder so the rungs
are made up of four smaller molecules
adenine thymine guanine and cytosine but
I'm just going to say 80 c and g and
what you'll notice is that a always goes
with t and g always goes with see they
always match up with each other on this
on the rungs of the ladder and the DNA
is it sort of contains the the
instructions for your body it it's in
every cell of your body in it and it
contains like a code of instructions
that tells your body how it's supposed
to grow and what kind of cells new cells
it's supposed to make what kind of
proteins it's supposed to make and where
those proteins should go so the the DNA
in one cell if it were all unwound and
stretched out would be about eight feet
long so it has to and you have about a
hundred trillion cells I think in your
body so
the DNA has to be packed really really
tightly to fit into all the cells of
your body so so it's wound into a double
helix but then it sort of winds up on
itself and its packed into this a unit
called a chromosome this kind of the
packaging unit of the DNA and the
chromosomes are in the nucleus the
nucleus is in the middle of the cell and
then you have about a hundred trillion
of these cells in your body and every
cell in a person's body has basically
the same the same DNA and humans have 46
of these chromosomes of these packaging
units in every nucleus of their cell and
you get half of you get half of these
chromosomes from your mother and half of
these chromosomes from your father so
all humans have have 46 but if you're a
girl you have to you have two X
chromosomes and if you're a boy you have
1x and one y chromosome so when um so be
you make you may have heard things on
again on the Discovery Channel or in the
news things to the effect that that all
humans pretty much have the same DNA
that we're about ninety-nine point nine
percent the same as far as our DNA goes
but they're so there are these tiny
differences about 0.001% and it doesn't
sound like a lot but the human genome
has about 3.3 billion of these letters
so one percent means that point 0 1
percent means that there are about 3
million small differences between each
person in their in their genes and the
way this happens is that whenever a cell
divides whenever cell makes a copy of
itself for example when a sperm cell or
in exile is being made the DNA has to
unwind the helix has to unwind and it
has to copy
self so two new strands have to be made
to make to two separate new DNA
molecules from the original DNA molecule
and when when the new strands are being
made sometimes there's a typo so
sometimes it doesn't copy itself exactly
and there's a there's a small mistake so
for example if your parents DNA had had
a sequence like this every once in a
while there's mistake so here's a G that
was put in instead of an a now the DNA
molecules in the nucleus of the cell
have their all kinds of proteins that
are floating around the DNA and that are
attached to the DNA when it's it's
copying itself and some of those
proteins are like a built-in correction
mechanism so when when these typos pop
up usually they're actually fixed before
they would ever see the light of day but
but every once in a while they're not
fixed and they make it through to the
the new egg or sperm cell and their
permanent once there's a typo like that
then it becomes part of the baby that's
born and and that person has that typo
in every cell of their body and that
typo ghen gets passed down to their
children so let's say a baby was born a
thousand years ago with a particular
type o every every descendant of theirs
their children and their grandchildren
has a chance of having this type o so
yeah well so you what we do is we use
these typos to you can trace them back
sort of like following the breadcrumbs
to find your way back home so because
these typos are permanent and they're
not necessarily bad just because it's a
mistake in the copying of the DNA it
doesn't mean that that they're actually
a bad thing most of them are random and
they don't necessarily affect your
health but they're just a record that we
can use to see who's related to who
because what happens is because the the
these changes are permanent and then
they can be passed down to future
generations then when you when you look
at a population today everybody who
shares the same version of the typo that
shares that piece of DNA they're all
related in some way yes so that's that's
the kind of evidence that we use to
figure out how individuals are related
to each other and how populations are
related to each other so so the work
that I do even though I'm I'm looking at
at DNA I concentrate on these typos when
when I collect data from DNA and I want
to collect a large number of I want to
collect information on a large number of
these typos because you can't just use
information from from one of these typos
to determine how people are are not
related to each other you need a lot of
independent pieces of data to determine
that
so I would normally try to collect data
from all the different chromosomes from
all 23 sets of chromosomes and look for
look for these typos which we call snips
single nucleotide polymorphisms or snips
and I would collect data from all 23
chromosomes so scientists in general
want to collect data that's that's
independent that means that so for
example if if you wanted me to give you
some information about Justin Bieber and
you wanted three pieces of information
about Justin Bieber I could tell you
he's a boy and he's he's male and he's
human but that's not really three
separate pieces of information because
by telling you that he's a boy I kind of
already told you that he's male and he's
human so if you wanted three separate
pieces of information about Justin
Bieber I might tell you he's a boy and
he's famous for his haircut and there's
a 3d movie about him so that's three
pretty pretty much separate pieces of
information about him so when I collect
data on snips I want the snip data to be
from all 23 different chromosomes so the
I don't want them to be snips that are
right next to each other on the same
chromosome because sometimes the
information is redundant and the the
populations that I've done a lot of work
with have actually been they live right
now in Thailand so the populations that
I study our tribal populations there are
relatively small populations that live
in Thailand but also in other parts of
Asia so these are populations that are
migratory that means they they move
around a lot and they move from one
country to another and they've been
moving for thousands of years and that's
part of what makes them interesting to
me because it's hard to know where they
came from and
they're their histories until maybe a
couple hundred years ago were not
written histories they didn't their
languages they didn't have written
languages so their histories were passed
down from one generation to the next
just through stories so there's no
because there's no written histories of
these of these tribal populations in
this part of Asia there's a lot of
speculation about where they came from
and people can interpret these oral
histories very differently depending on
what their kind of interests are you
know what they would they want to make
out of the stories so for some of these
tribal populations there are theories
like they're the Lost Tribe of Israel or
they came from Siberia sometimes people
think that they're you can use their
languages to determine where they came
from so if their languages seem really
similar to the languages of people from
a particular part of Asia then people
might think well they must have come
from that place too but there are
different ways for languages to be
passed on so that's not necessarily true
so so Thailand is is all the way over
here and we're here so I would travel to
Thailand to to collect saliva samples
from individuals of these tribal
populations and I didn't really want
their spit I wanted their their DNA but
there's a lot of DNA in your saliva so
people may be familiar with the idea
that you can scrape the inside of your
cheek to to get a DNA sample because
you're scraping the cells off the inside
of your cheek and in people saliva
there's some of these cells to some of
the cells on the inside of your cheek
they're constantly dying and you're
constantly making new ones so that's in
your and your spit but there's also a
lot of white blood cells in your spit
and so so this alive is a pretty good
source for DNA and I so i would i would
go to Thailand and
going to pass this around this is the
kind of kit that I use to collect a
saliva sample from somebody so you could
just you could pass this around but I
don't want anyone to spit in it because
I don't need your spit today so there's
inside this kit there's there's some
liquid and when you people spit in the
in the bottom part of the container and
then I twist the lid on and there's
liquid in the top of the lid that mixes
with the saliva and there are some
preservatives in the liquid that that
keep the DNA intact so DNA actually once
it's it's out of the cell it degrades
over time it falls apart and things like
heat or water can make it fall apart
faster and because I was going to be
traveling around Thailand and I wasn't
going to be near a refrigerator or
freezer and where where I was going in
Thailand it's either it's either really
hot we're really really hot so I'd be
driving around in like 120 degree
weather and then you know you put these
on an airplane and they are going to
freeze so so there's a preservative in
there that keeps the DNA intact even
when it's going through all of these
temperature changes and it's not being
refrigerated or frozen and and this
device is something that has been around
for maybe five or seven years and before
that it was it was a lot more difficult
to get a good DNA sample out of saliva
so people were relying a lot more on
blood samples but it's it's a lot harder
to convince somebody to to volunteer to
be stuck with a needle than it is to to
volunteer to spit into a container so so
this being able to get a really good DNA
sample out of out of saliva makes this
kind of work a lot easier because it's
just much easier to get people to
cooperate to spit into the container but
even even that it takes a good like 15
minutes for somebody to really fill up
the the kit and sometimes people get
embarrassed and they don't want to have
to spit in front of other people so they
sort of walked off and
you know if they try to find some
privacy to do their spitting umm so so
the part of Thailand that that I would
go to to collect these live samples was
way in the north and I don't know if you
can sort of see on a map help how bumpy
it looks in this region it's pretty
mountainous up here and the tribal
populations that live up here in the
mountains like I said they live in in
all of these other countries they live
in China but they move back and forth
across the borders into Thailand and
they've been in Thailand for you know
some of them anywhere from 50 years to a
couple hundred years but they've been
migrating through Asia for the past few
thousand years so so these are these are
language groups of some of the
populations that live in Asia and the
tribal populations that I'm talking
about are over here so I collected
samples from five tribal populations
Hmong Karan acha lahu and Lee Soo and so
this is sort of like a family tree of
their languages and it doesn't
necessarily mean that that the the
family tree their genetic family tree is
going to match up to this at all so so
there are some of the populations some
of the tribal populations have languages
that are pretty similar to each other
and there's one population the mom that
whose language is really a nice tool it
it's linguistics don't really know how
to categorize it so they keep moving it
around from different categories you
know every 20 years it's wreak a tiger
eyes by by linguists as something else
but but it seems really problematic to
categorize it so but I I collected
samples from from all five of these
tribal populations but I also collected
samples from people who say that all
four of their grandparents are tie and
from people who who say that all four of
their grandparents are Chinese there are
plenty of people living in Thailand who
who have
ancestry particularly in Bangkok so so I
also have samples from from those
individuals so so to collect these
samples I would have to I went a number
of times to Thailand and I would have to
go all the way into the north into these
mountains so this was like my office
it's a rough job but it looks like a
painting but it's real so I would wake
up in the morning and this is what I
would see and then we'd set out I when
you do this kind of work particularly in
another country you can't do it by
yourself you can't just land somewhere
and and ask people for their DNA you
need to get permission from your
university in the United States you need
to get permission from a local
university in the country that you're
working in and you need to get a lot of
people a lot of local people to help you
because you don't know where you're
going and you need translators and when
you're working somewhere like this to
get into the mountains the you can only
go during part of the year that's when
it's the dry season because during the
rainy season the roads wash out and
there are mud slides so so you really
need like an expert driver to take you
there you need to go with somebody who
knows where they're going and who knows
where it is or isn't safe so so we go
into the mountains the the the tribal
populations that I was dealing with our
farmers and you can you can see on the
mountainside some of the the crops that
they have planted and here they they've
cut they've this is something kind of
farming called terracing where they've
cut into the side of the mountain so
it's it's really hard to farm on a steep
mountainside so they they cut slices
into the mountain to make like multiple
flat areas for their for their farming
and there are these little villages that
are dotted all over the mountain ranges
and so like I said the it's it's pretty
hard to navigate around their most
people have motorbikes they don't have
car
is so these are some of the people who
who helped me I had the three people in
the middle our nurses who would go with
me and who were my translators and these
were to forestry Rangers forest police
who knew the area really well and they
were with us and this guy actually ran
health clinics for a lot of the the
people who gave me saliva samples who he
basically personally knew everybody who
who we came in contact with and that was
really helpful so so we were staying for
this particular trip we were staying at
a forestry station at the top of the
mountains so we pack up our truck in the
morning with our supplies including the
the spit collection kits and we drive
around to get to the villages but
sometimes the truck overheats and you
just have to that's one thing that you
learn when you're working somewhere when
you're not working in the United States
and and you realize you have to go with
the flow that thing so you make a plan
for the day but it just doesn't always
work and then he got a you got to move
to plan B really quickly so so we'd land
in in these villages and the villages
had been contacted beforehand by the
people who were working with me so they
knew that we were coming and these
villages typically have one man who's
elected for the year to be kind of in
charge of the village so if my
assistants contacted a village and the
head man said you know we're not
interested in participating we don't
want you to come then we just we
wouldn't show up so so all the villages
that we visited knew that we were coming
and they knew what day we were coming
and so so each village typically has
some kind of central area where people
get together in meet and you know talk
they may have their their meetings there
they may have religious services there
so we would kind of park ourselves in
this central meeting place and that way
people could if they were interested in
participating
pating they could show up and if they if
they didn't really want to participate
they could just stay home they could
avoid us this we decided that this was
better than going door-to-door and sort
of confronting people and then they
might they might say yes even if they
didn't really want to say yes and that's
kind of putting a lot of pressure on
people so we decided it was better to
just hang out in one place and people
could could participate if they wanted
to and avoid us if they didn't want to
so we had consent forms that were in
Thai and these were explained to people
but most of the people don't read or
write so they had to they would sign the
consent form by putting their thumbprint
on it instead of their signature and
then people would line up and start
spitting in the in the collection kits
their work at these Pete they're working
really hard they really are this is my
favorite my favorite picture I wanted to
frame it and put it up in my house but
my kids did not want me to do that I
guess I'm used to looking at it so it
doesn't bother me so so people would
start spitting in the in the containers
and then sometimes they would they would
all they would all start coming up to me
and handing me these containers really
fast and there would be like a backlog
of spit it would be screwing the tops on
really quickly but you have to make sure
that you screw them on you know really
carefully so we don't leak out when
you're taking them home on the airplane
so so I'd end up with with a bunch of
saliva collection kits and
no so so you know it depends what kind
of study you're doing I didn't this was
I was collecting anonymous population
samples the only thing that I needed to
know from these people was are you at
least 18 years old are you agreeing to
do this you know of your own accord and
are all four of your grandparents from
this particular tribe I didn't want to
know anything else about them so if
you're doing a medical genetic study
where you really need to trace certain
information about like what kind of
disease somebody has and how sick they
are back to a specific DNA sample you'd
have to label it and I didn't I didn't
have to do that yeah so so when you get
the the DNA back to the lab and even
even this was tricky that the first time
that I went was before the shoe bomber
and part of this work was for my
doctoral thesis so I had spent about two
years writing grants and and then I
travel to the other side of planet and I
collect the saliva samples so when I
brought them back with me on the plane I
put it all in my carry-on luggage i had
about the first time i went i had a
couple hundred saliva samples and I
packed them all into my carry-on bag and
I figured you know the airlines can lose
the rest of my luggage that I checked
but I need this spit and and I never got
stopped I don't I rarely get stopped in
airports I guess I don't look scary so
no one ever really stopped me to look
through my luggage but I was thinking
and I had a lot of paperwork with me to
try to explain it if somebody did look
through my luggage but I got lucky and
nobody looked but then after that
between then and the next time that I
went there was a shoe bomber incident so
you could no longer bring liquids on a
plane and I was terrified the next time
I came back what am I going to do with
my spit I have to actually check it and
the luggage and I was really scared that
you know what happens if the airline
loses my precious spit so I divided it
up into two different suitcases and I
put half from each village in each
suitcase so that
if one entire suitcase was lost I would
still have a sample from from each
village to to get the the geographic
range that I had worked so hard to get
so so then if you come back and you have
it was really exciting to be able to
collect all of these all of these
samples but then you have to open them
and and it can be a little gross okay
but but you know you're excited because
you really want to get the DNA out of it
so so when you're motivated it's not as
gross so in the lab you have to you have
to take the saliva out of the little kit
and put it in a test tube and add some
chemicals to it to make the cells burst
open so that the DNA will come out of
the cells and you add different you have
different chemicals to the the tube than
to get rid of the protein and DNA the
molecule DNA likes water it's happy
around water so you pour alcohol into
the tube and the DNA molecules are it's
almost like they're they're afraid of
alcohol they need to avoid the alcohol
so they all sort of clump together to
get away from the alcohol and they form
this blob and this is really what it
looks like you can see this big blob you
know hopefully of DNA appear in the tube
like a cloud and that's always a
wonderful moment so it's really exciting
after you you you know traveled that far
and you've worked so hard to collect
these samples and you pour the alcohol
into the tube you shake it back and
forth a few times and then poof there's
a big cloud of DNA every once in a while
there's a sample that just sort of
stinks it just failed and you know
somebody gave you a lot of spit but they
just there's not a lot of DNA in the
tube and so you turn it back and forth
they put after putting the alcohol in it
and you're waiting waiting for that
cloud of DNA to appear and it just sort
of doesn't but no no it doesn't kill it
it's just causing it's just causing it
to form a clump and then you can put it
in a centrifuge and
and spin it down to make the clump go
all the way to the bottom of the tube so
that you can you can extract the DNA
from from the tube so in total I went I
mean I've been to Thailand about eight
different times to work on on these
projects but I think only three of them
for only three of them I was collecting
samples so I have a little over 500
samples so far so so like I said when I
when I get these samples there there are
many different ways to collect
information on the snips on the typos
and I'm not going to go into the details
of that right now but but I collected
information on about 2500 of these
little typos all over the genome from
all 23 chromosomes and and I had that
information like I said on the samples
that that I had collected in Thailand
but there are also databases there are
public databases that anybody can access
you don't have to be a researcher and
and it's free you don't have to pay for
it so there are public databases that
have the same kind of information on on
these typos for many different
populations that have been collected
from all over the world so I was able to
combine the information that I had
collected with information from these
public databases using populations many
other populations from from Asia and
that was really helpful to me because
then I could I could compare my
populations to the all of these other
populations from all over Asia to try to
figure out which of these other
populations which of the other Asian
populations do my populations look the
most like genetically and and which ones
do they do they not look alike so you
can also see things like migration
between populations you can you know a
lot of populations a lot of human
populations have cultural rules like you
only marry somebody from within your
your particular culture or your
grandmother is going to kill
right so and there are a lot of
populations that claim that that's what
they do but there's no such thing I mean
all human populations are constantly
migrated there's constantly migration
between all human populations there's no
such thing as an isolated population or
a closed population even if that's what
people say so so one thing that you can
look at with this kind of information is
the extent to which there's a
discrepancy so all of these populations
claim that you know you only supposed to
marry within the tribe but then when you
look at the genetic data you can really
see how much a movement there is between
these populations and how how much sort
of trading there is going on between the
populations of trading of people between
the populations so one thing you can see
you know the relationships between their
languages so one thing that's true is
that if you if you can't speak someone
else's language it's not likely that
you're going to marry them and have kids
with them it just makes it a lot more
difficult so when people speak languages
that are that are more similar you'd
expect that it would be easier to learn
the other person's language and there's
going to be more movement between
populations that have similar languages
and and that is that is some of some of
what you find so one thing that that I
found was that all of these populations
are a southern Asian in origin compared
to Japanese the Japanese population was
one of the populations that I was able
to get from the public database and I
also found that that out of the the five
tribal populations that I looked at
these four are more similar to each
other and this this one population the
mom are sort of outliers so even though
all of these populations are southern
Asian in origin the Hmong seemed to be
an outlier compared to the rest of these
tribal populations and their language is
also an outlier so it's really difficult
for the people of these other groups to
be able to speak the Hmong language and
it really does seem like that ends up
being a barrier for people moving back
and forth between those populations one
other thing that I found is that out of
all five of the tribal populations these
two the lee soo and the LA who are
genetically most similar to each other
so even though the Lahu language is
closer to the aqua language these two
have a lot in common genetically and
there's there's not really there's no
way to know whether that's because they
they originally were very different and
that they've shared a lot that there
have been a lot of people moving back
and forth recently or is it because this
this similar similarity and language
between atha and la who is not that that
maybe one of them adopted the language
sort of after the fact so maybe their
languages are really similar not because
they they're genetically similar but
because one of them adopted the language
at a later time but the but it is true
that out of these three populations
their languages are similar enough that
a lot of the men do speak one or more of
the languages of the other populations
and they do a lot of business and
trading with each other so that's the
kind of thing that increases the chance
that they're going to also be trading
marriage partners between the
populations so that's that is actually
what you see and another interesting
thing that I found was that even though
overall all of these populations are are
generally southern Asian in origin
compared to the japanese there's a small
piece of ancestry in the quran
population that actually looks a lot
like the Japanese and and Japan is
pretty far away from from where these
people are living right now so that
could be one explanation for that is
that
but the is that the the ancestry in the
Quran that looks a lot like the Japanese
is a remnant of an ancient population
that may be from the area of Tibet and
that when people were migrating north to
to Japan part of the population that
that eventually contributed to the
Japanese was incorporated into what's
now what's now the the current
population but so so some of when you do
this kind of work when you're taking a
data or information from populations
that exists today and then you're trying
to extrapolate the past you're trying to
figure out the past you your net you can
never be totally sure you can come up
with probabilities you can come up with
inferences but and you can come up with
theories that that make that makes sense
considering what you're looking at today
but you can never be totally sure about
what you're piecing together but but for
me just doing this kind of work in of
itself is just interesting enough for
for me but there are some applications
to this kind of work so aside from being
able to make really good discovery
channel movies out of it so so there
there are you know you some of you may
have heard of companies that you can use
like the same kind of spit kit and and
i'll tell you about your genetic
ancestry so the same kind so some of the
same kind of work that i do is they're
using the same kind of data and these
companies are using the same kind of
data and the same kind of computer
programs and statistics that that I
would use they're using those same kinds
of things to to give you information
about your ancestry but but this kind of
information is also applicable now to
personalized medicine which is something
that we keep hearing about interviews as
this thing that's going to happen that
that's you know about to happen but
totally happened yet so so information
about about ancestry is is also
applicable to to medicine which is which
is why I actually work even though I'm
trained as an anthropologist i work at
yale in the psychiatry department in a
psychiatric genetics lab where they're
doing Studies on the genetics of
different kinds of psychiatric illnesses
and different kinds of substance abuse
disorders because they need to know a
lot about the ancestry of the
individuals that that they're working on
in the lab so that's that's about it but
I'll take questions people have them way
let's first of all this is a little gift
from us at sign Saturday's are there any
questions first of all don't go away
because I have an announcement okay so
let's ask some questions and then we'll
get to the second part
is it could you say that again yes
yes oh okay it's this is a this is just
a language thats related to japanese
it's just showing the relationships
between some of the language families
here but i didn't include individuals
from who speak that branch of japanese
that's not really likely because you see
it even even when you take samples of
quran from multiple locations so so one
thing that can happen is if you if you
sample a population from one location
and and you assume okay this is going to
represent you know i'm going to sample
quran from one village and and then you
make the assumption that that represents
quran genetic diversity no matter where
current are even though there are n
livin all over asia that could be a
mistake you could end up just getting a
picture of this one village that you
know so maybe some japanese people just
landed in that particular village so
you'd be making a mistake so one thing I
was really careful to do is to get
samples from multiple villages for every
population that I collected I i went to
multiple villages but also i can i can
go back from different provinces in in
thailand from different from different
mountain ranges where it would be okay
so so I i was in this mountain range
over here and also this mountain range
over here so so it's just if you're if
you end up seeing the same picture from
multiple villages then
then you can be pretty sure that that
you're looking at something consistent
and that's that's representative of the
population as a whole right right oh
yeah so so it is it is a normal process
every time a cell divides there's
potential for these typos to occur and
they do occur but like I said most of
them are actually fixed before they ever
in it before they ever make it into into
a baby but the these typos occur all
over the genome and they so most of the
genome doesn't make up proteins most of
the genome does not contain information
to create proteins so so these are just
they're not necessarily affecting
anybody's health where the color of
anybody's hair but but I can use them as
a record of the past there are plenty of
snips that do cause differences between
the way people look or between know
people's health or between you know how
tall or short somebody is but those are
not the kinds of snips that I'm that I'm
looking at
so I for this particular study I only
wanted to look at asian populations so
even though the even the populations
that I used from the database were were
just from Asia but snips accumulate in
in populations over time so so one of
the things that that you find is that
enough not for an individual necessarily
but if you look at the population as a
whole because humans originated in
Africa African populations overall
contain more genetic variation than
non-african populations that's one of
the ways that we know that that those
are older populations because the the
variation accumulates over time over
generations so I didn't include African
populations in this study but it's been
shown repeatedly that African
populations contain more more of these
snips more genetic variation overall
than non-african populations and that's
a function of how old the populations
are one more question right why so a lot
of people ask me that so why was I in
Thailand I'm interested in in the
answering theoretical questions so I had
an opportunity to go do this study in
Thailand because the lab that I was
working with the the psychiatric
genetics lab that I was working with was
doing a study starting a study in
Thailand on the genetics of opiate abuse
and methamphetamine abuse in cooperation
with the Thai government and with some
some universities in in Thailand and so
they were they needed to work with high
populations and they needed information
on the genetic ancestry of these
populations and you know how how they're
related to each other because they
needed that for their further studies so
I was sort of able to tack on my my work
for my doctorate to what they were doing
but if they if if I had had an
opportunity if
come to me and said you know we want to
study the genetics of psoriasis and
South American tribal populations I
would have said well I'll go there no I
I mean for me I I want to answer the
theoretical questions so these happen to
be good populations to work with and
Talan is a great place to go and the
food is fantastic and it was really
beautiful and so so right i mean you saw
those pictures so i would get there and
I'd be like oh I'm working I'm where
it's so hard you know well I'm eating
fruit that was just picked off a tree so
you know I was just really lucky I was
really lucky that I had that opportunity
but i would have gone I would have gone
somewhere else right these are great
questions let's think I think speaker
again